I know your fears
I know your weaknesses
I know you better than you know yourselves
Savitar is still out there
I'll be ready.
you will feel my wrath
the wrath of savitar
please tell me you're seeing him
oooh, I see him
holy crap, everybody so much happening in
this flash winter finale footage let's break
it down and heads up the flash ring giveaway
is back for those asking all you have to do
to enter just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video and make sure you turn
alerts on there is crazy stuff happening this
month so oh my God I cannot believe their
actually getting this close to Mark Hamill
Joker on the flash.
I think what's going on here is that he just
made to look like the Joker but he still playing
earth three trickster the James Jesse trickster,
so Jay Garrick looks like he's been running
afoul him for a long time, now Barry has to
go to earth read to get help with savitar.
This is all stuff that's happening after the
crossover, so the official synopsis just reads
that the Doctor alchemy's savitar team up.
It just way too much for Barry to handle.
So is getting super bummed out about Christmas
can't handle.
Like any of the real life stuff is going on.
All he can think about's savitar and Doctor
alchemy.
So even though Wally tries to help out just
like he helped out during the crossover areas
and super happy about that just because he's
worried about Wally getting hurt like rushing
into things too fast.
So he goes to earth three gets help from Jay
Garrick it looks like he helps Jay Garrick
with his trickster problem then they both
come back in Jay Garrick helps out with savitar,
but you seem like falling off the building
here.
So they really want you to think that something
really bad as can happen to Jay Garrick but
TV likes to play a lot of tricks on you like
think about what just happened to Wally he
came and had a really awesome takedown in
this last episode of the flash but then Supergirl
put him on his ass, so he was out of commission
for little while but even if something terrible
happens to Jay Garrick just think about the
Ronnie Raymond firestorm multi-verse workaround.
So Robbie Amell gets questions all the time
about if he's ever coming back to the flash,
are you ever going to play the Ronnie Raymond
firestorm again and he's like well there's
a multi-verse out there Supergirl is confirmed
on earth 38 that's 36 other versions that
could be out there because earth two Ronnie
Raymond death store may he rest in peace,
also died during flash season two let's talk
about trickster stuff first so Mark Hamill
coming for the midseason finale is now a three
time tradition, so that makes me wonder what
the going to try and do with him next year
it just that there's like a break in his Star
Wars filming schedule that allows them to
do this, so I'm so happy about it because
usually he has to shave he is to grow the
beard out for Luke.
So I.
So, so is a question of what his availability
is going to be because next year they'll be
episode nine filming going on so hopefully
he's done in time to come back for another
episode of the flash next year.
Having him around the such a big deal one
because he's a really big actor to because
he's an amazing actor in three because is
really big character with a long history of
Jay Garrick Jon Wesley Shipp Barry Allen stuff,
so Jon Wesley Shipp has talked a lot about
his version of Jay Garrick on the flash he's
calling him like his version of Barry from
the original 90s flash series just 20+ years
into the future, so pretend that the world
of earth three is the world of that 90s flash
series the big difference with the comics
multi-verse in the TV show multi-verse is
that earth three in the comics is crime syndicate
earth in they kind of did that with earth
two with this big evil meta-team up this zoom
had in season two it's kinda funny but you
see that the bomb strapped to his chest.
You see a theme start to appear the first
episode he had where he teamed up with his
son the second version of the trickster he
had a bomb strapped to his chest is gonna
blow bunch of people up the second time he
came back in season two.
He was also trying to blow up half of the
city with a bunch of bombs and presents.
So will be fun to see what he tries to blow
up this year but I love Mark Hamill he's one
of the best character actors.
Most people just think about Luke Skywalker
Star Wars stuff but he's done so much animated
voiceover work the Joker is just the biggest
character that everybody remembers thinking
I laugh.
I'm on the freeway someone in Los Angeles
not let me know in the comments what is your
favorite Mark Hamill character that is not
Luke Skywalker.
I feel like we can all say that the Joker
is probably our favorite Mark Hamill character
everybody loves Luke Skywalker, but his Joker
is so timeless and what about all this savitar
Doctor alchemy stuff is going on in the episode,
most of you probably noticed that Doctor alchemy
is speaking with a different voice in this
trailer then he was in the first couple of
episodes that he appeared in this season that
is now because I think that that original
voice when we first heard him speak was speaking
with savitar's voice, the voiceover you here
in this trailer is all Doctor alchemy, there's
no savitar speaking.
I mean, he appears in the trailer but he doesn't
speak he talks about knowing all their secrets
all their weaknesses.
It shows you Iris West.
So you start to put two and two together and
you like all.
What if something happens to Iris West because
during the crossover episode we saw a future
newspaper that was not written by Iris West,
so a lot of you guys would like wait a minute.
Does that mean that she dies in the current
version of events.
So the gonna try and change that the season
Candice Patton is always going to be a big
character on the flash like the neck in a
kill off Iris West for good the flash is one
of those TV shows though where they can have
moments like that where they kill someone
and then bring it right back just because
of all the ways that people's powers work,
and there's a lot this season that they're
doing with the flash is powers that we haven't
seen before.
The way they characterize the speed force.
This savitar character who is a little full
metal alchemist if you guys haven't seen that
series full metal alchemist brotherhood has
a character that's essentially like a soul
bonded to a suit of armor.
So even though there's a person in that suit
of armor.
There's no physical body like his consciousness
is in there, so that might be what's happening
with savitar.
It's also kind of a super deep cut but during
the Stargate TV series there was a character
called Anubis it was like 1/2 ascended being
that existed in this in between.
Sort of trans-dimensional state where he could
kind of assume a semi-corporeal form, but
the beings like the higher beings that existed
in that universe could not act against him,
the kind of like the all-powerful God like
the speed force wormhole aliens that we saw
during the flash season two that Barry met
inside the speed force because he existed
in this in between state between pure God
and pure normal person like Barry almost no
one could act against him, so that might be
why savitar is so much more of a threat than
zoom because zoom was really powerful.
He was faster than Barry, but when he messed
with time too much the speed force itself
acted against him since the time wraiths and
turned him into the black flash carrying them
off.
But then, of savitar, so bad.
How come that doesn't happen to him it just
feels like the show has been telling us that
he exists in this in between state like we
see him running through pure speed force,
not three-dimensional space.
So, I know it sounds a little confusing but
just imagine someone traveling as pure energy
that's kind of what it would look like to
the human eye like he appears in a bolt of
lightning when he's fighting Barry, but it
sounds like he's stuck in that state like
he can't completely manifest of physical body
in the real world and that's what he's trying
to do with the help of Doctor alchemy, I know
a lot of your wondering if this is a version
of future Barry like the blue flash from the
comics.
I don't think the show is that pessimistic.
I don't think it would go down that route,
but ultimately they want you the writers want
you to believe in Barry.
So I be blown away if the ever actually turned
Barry into a villain of the series.
There is always going to do really stupid
stuff but ultimately the idea is that he's
the hero of the series, so they don't ever
want to poison the audience against Barry
like they don't want you to root against Barry,
but I can only imagine how the Iris West super
fans are going to write it when savitar ultimately
takes a swipe at her even though the show
would never killer off but that doesn't mean
that she's a mutant from evil speedsters and
alchemy says in the trailer, I know all your
weaknesses.
Speaking of which, Doctor alchemy, we pretty
much know what's going on with his character
so what is up with the Julian character, it
sounds like they're going with the split personality
situation because Julian himself seems like
he doesn't hate Barry, but this alchemy persona
seems like he's trying to bring about this
grand apocalypse, so that savitar can come
back but you do wonder if it's like a firestorm
situation like house the TV show going to
address this multiple personality is it like
firestorm whereby like when Doctor alchemy
is doing stuff the Julian consciousness is
still aware of what's going on even though
he's not fully in control and that's probably
something words can have to wait to find out
because Tom Felton is going to be a big character
for the entire season so the probably get
take their time explaining what the hell is
going on with Doctor alchemy even though we
kind of know what the identity twist is we
just don't know the reason behind it yet,
you guys can let me know like what is your
theory behind Doctor alchemy in Julian Albert
is he really an evil person or is it a split
personality and what you think is good happened
to Jay Garrick.
Do you think that savitar will just almost
kill him put him out of commission.
So that quota quote yes to go away for a couple
episodes before he can come back like they
use them very sparingly that there's very
little Jay Garrick the season so far and.
A lot of you have been asking me about Jay
Garrick on legends of tomorrow.
I ultimately think he'll eventually go there.
I haven't seen any confirmation from the producers
or the actors that they're actually going
to do that but Jon Wesley Shipp himself said
that he felt like they were probably going
to do that he just kinda did that thing that
we all do worth like will Jay Garrick is a
huge justice society character, they're doing
just a society on the TV shows that it makes
sense that they would try to find a place
for them to talk a little bit more about that
when I post my legends video this week that's
Thursday it will be the fourth night of the
crossover, you guys can let me know if you
been finding my crossover videos just fine
I put different titles on the thumbnails just
to distinguish them from normal episode like
part one part two part three and then part
four.
So there's only four parts the crossover so
I just put those on their so you would know
which order the episodes are happening in
in which order to watch the videos and you
don't have to watch them in order, but I just
put those on their in case people have no
idea what's going on, but what can happen
next is I'm in a do a.
Rick and Morty season three trailer video.
If you have no idea what that show is I'll
try to explain the be a couple more bonus
videos, but that's getting ready to get started,
so I'll explain that video there was also
new agents of shield.
There was a different ghost rider that appeared
big twist so that video might not post till
Thursday but I will do an agents of shield
ghostwriter video just because of all the
DC craziness this week A lot of other stuff
that is in not an emergency is second priority.
So don't worry agents of shield coming.
Rick and Morty coming next and then Arrow
100th episode so get hype while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for my
crossover Part two video and you can click
here for the part one video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight!